[Music]
especially with even like corona it's
like am i going to put
a a germ corro am i going to put
a dollar bill under her i mean she could
get covered in the eye right
so now it's like i guess i'll just vent
i got to venmo her
[Laughter]
from the tooth fairy tooth fairy
gmail.com and i'm like just check if you
have anything from him
yeah she's like because of covert she
can't go to houses she can't go to
houses tooth fairy it's too much germs
yeah and there's
tooth fairy where's the mask and
everything's hysterical you're gonna
have to venmo
everything i'm gonna that's what it is
cassandra can't come in either no
nobody's coming unless you got a mask on
you want to
know the fact that like santa doesn't
really come in your bedroom
no santa goes in the living room unless
you sleep unless your room is the one
that has the chimney which it's just bad
luck yeah but that's the odds are low
yeah that's a low if you're the baby
with the chimney in your room yeah i
mean i
mean i don't even know i only know three
people that had the chimney in their
rooms and
i know they're all [ __ ] up now man no
but like santa's going into communal
space
other people are in the home yeah but
this woman thinks she's gonna sneak in
the middle of night in the dark come in
my room
this is a safety zone well let me ask
yeah because the thing is with santa now
it's like let me ask you this
santa okay so santa comes to my house i
live in new york when he goes to florida
is he waiting there for 14 days is he
quarantining
after he drops those pictures you can't
it can't unless unless someone's gonna
drop us
a memo that christmas is is is is months
long
yeah he can't do his job under the
current conditions and he's not above
the law
no he bet well he may think he is but i
get i
tell you what he's going to find out
that would be an interesting december
absolutely it's going to be very first
one of our lives yeah because how is he
going to get all these gifts with
quarantine i don't know how he's going
to do it
and then yeah am i do i have to
disinfect i don't know what the hell's
going on in the north pole would have
been there or should have they were they
like sweden where everything was open
what are the corona numbers so they go
year round they don't have time to sleep
they have no time they're telling me if
one gets in if one [ __ ] dopey elf
gets infected they're all gone that's it
they're all done sneezy you think i'm
[ __ ] trustees
[Laughter]
i don't care if he has a mask on if
you're just sneezing non-stop behind the
mask
oh i don't care that n95 is gonna it
only has so much power in it no
no yeah so i'm holding power i've got
nothing to do no you ever see a sneeze
in slow motion on youtube
it's disgusting don't you ever seen a
fart on on uh
the red light you ever you're like like
when the smoke actually comes out of the
ass or whatever
yeah and like in like when people fart
when people find metal detectors and the
x-ray machines
we're gonna look at that's
once we get this this studio up to the
where we're going to have it that's
going to be the first video we watch
yeah you and by the way if you've never
seen a sneak like a slow motion sneeze
i'm going to tell you don't don't go
look at it because
i live my life a certain way because
i've been exposed to things like this
right
you see when someone sneezes it is
similar to like someone bombing us
really like it is it is
billions i mean you can't even it comes
out at 100 miles an hour and it covers
the whole room in the cloud of the
of their germs and that's what they're
saying like droplets you know drops
right
yeah like we're throwing droplets back
and forth right now we're doing it right
now which is also why i was hesitant to
do any shows
right because if we're doing our job
right everyone's laughing and coughing
and
and slapping and going yeah yeah and
that's what we
do everywhere that's like yeah good news
for you though and me and doing this
podcast is i have a deviated septum so i
can't get a sneeze out
so i'll always i'll always be and it
won't come out you don't sneeze
i've never produced a sneeze in my life
i swear to god this is quite yeah
yes it's very wet and i've went you know
one concert never sneezed
never sneezed no goat cheese no no pork
chop
never saw trading places yeah never saw
santa was my stepfather yeah i'm saying
it was just that phony yeah
that is wild that's an episode
you